What the fuck?
Stuttgart 21, eines der ambitioniertesten
Bauprojekte der Deutschen Bahn, ...
... hätte letztes Jahr fertiggestellt werden müssen.
Na ja.
Da, wo früher Stuttgart war,
ist aber nun eine riesige Baustelle.
Ich will jetzt mal herausfinden,
was die Stuttgarter davon halten, ...
... wenn ich denn den Weg in diesen Bahnhof finde.
Wenn ich Stuttgart finde.
I’ll find it out.
Ja, was halten Sie denn von
dem neuen Bahnhof Stuttgart 21?
Also schön wird er, aber es wird Zeit,
dass er mal fertig wird.
Das Geilste ist, wenn dein ICE
vielleicht eine Verspätung hat ...
... und du dann die geilen Umleitungen
hier benutzen musst.
What the fuck?
Hektar besteht, Liebe vergeht.
Ach Mensch.
Überraschung.
Baustelle!
Für immer bin ich in diesem Tunnel gefangen.
Ich werde den Stuttgarter Bahnhof
nie verlassen können.
Das habe ich jetzt zum Beispiel
auch noch nicht gesehen.
Finde ich spannender wie jeder Krimi.
Also ich war tatsächlich für Stuttgart 21, ...
... nicht wissend, was das für ein Spektakel gibt.
Ich bete für euch, meine Freunde,
ich bete für euch.
Ich bin jetzt hier seit irgendwie, keine Ahnung, hunderten von Metern unterwegs, ...
... um den Bahnhof mal zu verlassen,
mal an der Basis nachfragen.
Ist aber nicht.
Gibt's mehr Kräne, als ich Freunde habe,
sage ich ganz ehrlich: Mir reicht's, Stuttgart.
Was ist mit dir?
Oh!
Zehn MilliardenEuro.
Wer soll das bezahlen?
Ja, die nachfolgende Generationen.
Wir Älteren können es nicht mehr bezahlen.
Also das sehe ich nicht so.
- Also, dir gefällt's?
Ich finde Stuttgart 21
das Richtige für Stuttgart.
Bisher finde ich alles an Stuttgart 21
ziemlich schlecht, ...
... weil es unsere komplette Stadt zerstört
und ich glaube, das dauert noch eine Weile.
Ja, dauert noch eine Weile.
*Lachen*
Ich habe heute viele verschiedene
Stimmen zu Stuttgart 21 gehört.
Ich habe aber auf jeden Fall das Gefühl, ...
... die Deutsche Bahn hat sich für dieses ambitionierte Bauprojekt die richtige Stadt ausgesucht, ...
... weil die schwäbische Gelassenheit,
die setzt sich hier immer noch durch.
Ich gehe jetzt zurück nach Berlin.
Tschüssle, Ciao, Ade!
Wir sehen uns im Stadtcafé.
Wo ist mein Zug?
Ankunft 16:39.
Heute Ausgleich. Neun. Ich wiederhole.